le podcast est présente et commanditée
par jus frais jus frais c'est l'énergie
c'est les meilleures juste et des jus
fait à la main des jus naturel avec des
vrais fruits fait par fils lui-même le
président fondateur de jus frais comment
se laver puis le lendemain il vient chez
toi à vauréal te porter jus pour 3 2
lors des livraisons
sinon elle peut renvoyer par postes
canada partout au québec
c'est vraiment des bons jours ne s'ouvre
à partouzes autres sont délicieux il ya
vraiment du goût le poignant le comment
j'ai rarement goûté la ma vie ouais puis
on note en exclusivité la chance aussi
fils vient de porter ces nouveaux jeux
pour qu'on les tests qu'ont les essais
qu'on me donne aux commentaires on a la
chance de goûter à ce nouveau jus pis
elle au moment où ce qu'on vous parle en
ce moment il ya un nouveau jeu
disponible sur jus frais points c'est à
qui le morning power si j'allais goûter
personnellement c'est un genre du bray
dans le mood 6 juin c'est vraiment
vraiment bon qu'ils puissent à kester
est votre journée comme du monde
on a un code promo pour vous autres
parce que fait le réussi à réduire les
coûts est en est qu'il y augmenter son
volume donc il peut vous offrir un
meilleur rabais à la place de 15% ses
20% maintenant en utilisant un code
promo s f 20 / geoffrey point ses
affects merci à la gagne de chez jus
frais puis merci à vous autres des
encours se la joue c'est dans l'épisode
de cette semaine est également présentée
par même skate vous savez on a passé
l'année 2020 pas mal en mouche et nous a
pas trop prendre soin de soi mais j'ai
découvert que 1 prenant soin de soi on
se sent mieux on sent plus confortable
et quelle meilleure façon de prendre
soin de soi que se raser sous la
ceinture avec un instrument de qualité
c'est le cas ici avec le perfect package
3.0 de même skype qui contient entre
autres le lower 3.0 qui est ici qui
possède une technologie scps insafe sait
ce que ça veut dire
six clubs playboy c'est aussi simple que
ça moi je l'essayé deux mots si qui est
passionné en ce moment par la lecture de
de ces nouvelles la guerre c'est
vraiment un outil incroyable pour vrai
si vous voulez vous débarrasser de ce
poids dans cette région le sait la chose
là qui veulent mieux que j'ai jamais
essayé dans ma vie c'est un instrument
parfait pour ce papa de sfar malpas pas
de scoop est vraiment ça va très bien
pied mot j'avouerai même que des fois je
l'utilisent pour d'autres choses que
cette région le cerveau encore aussi
bien pigé pas par adulte et jeune papa
de l'oedt est un malade il ya beaucoup
de personnes qui m'ont écrit en fait
personnellement sur mon compte instagram
pour me dire qu'ils avaient acheté ce
soit pour quelqu'un dans leur vie ou
pour l'heure comme les gosses en avons
un bon message qui est tout le monde
aime ça
avoir des bols clean pas trop de poils
bien entretenu puis en plus de ceux on a
deux autres choses ici que d'hommes
tient en ce moment c'est quoi ce cirque
qui viennent à la perfecta qui trôna de
crop réservé quittant ses écrits bol des
eaux de rennes ça veut dire lundi à doha
pour base pour couilles
alors à défaut de vous mettez ça puis
vous assurer que toute la journée y
avait pas d'odeur qui ce qui se crée qui
se forment
ça sent toujours frais en turban pile de
crêpes revival de balle tourne c'est
ainsi que vous mettez sur pour un
extrait une extra frais chambre c'est
vraiment super ces croyants c'est
l'abandon pour 2021
ainsi de toujours être à votre meilleur
préparez-vous comme si vous rentrez au
travers lui même si vous restez chez
vous probablement journée longue on a un
code promo pour vous qui est sans filtre
en un seul mot c'est 20% of plus le
shipping gratuit 20 % gratuit ça
commence à faire des bons rabais
l'effectuent qu'est ce c'est vraiment le
temps de changer vos habitudes votre
routine d'hygiène dans der commis 10 fév
merci à la gagne de minsk et puis merci
à vous
rouyère
une production du studio sfr néo sans
filtre le podcast on parle lorsqu'on
voit que nos invités date et chez ph
quand un mois d'une plante cette semaine
d'un homme seul son fils très très
spécial cette semaine effectivement mon
ph un épisode on reçoit lisanne nadeau
et joanie docteur point g pour parler de
leur nouveau projet nouveau podcast se
tourne ici au studio sur lesquels on
travaille avec eux sur l'élaboration de
ce projet là depuis quelques semaines
mois des jeux ses droits ce par la faute
d'un podcast de sexualité qui va
paraître vraiment bientôt puis le
podcast
on tombe un petit peu on compte des
histoires un petit peu trop personnelle
de fois maman si tu écoutes le podcast
change
changeux changer vos écoutes et un autre
très bon épisode à guillaume dulude pour
ma mère le quai coûtait un break d'une
minute qui vient de sortir le volet
coûté lui mais pour lui s'il faut pas
que les mères écoute cet épisode
s'il vous plaît c'est de serment drôle
on parle de pleine affaire des justement
de
leurs podcasts les fils leurs
expériences sexuelles pourquoi tu
voulais faire un peu de casse pour
parler d'autres se joue à nick est une
experte des jouets sexuels puis de
l'épanouissement sexuel seront aspar
intéressant on en a parlé un petit peu
de lisandro s'ils sont sa participation
imminente à droite parce que les
concepteurs qui depuis sa relation avec
l'alcool aussi calquer la coupe et ça
c'est super intéressant aussi
mais principalement on parle de sexe on
parle de cul l'on parle de sous toutes
ses coutures
alors ses coutures afone way puis si
vous aimez la conversation qu'on vient
d'avoir avec les feuilles définitivement
vous allez aimer leur podcast puis à
l'électrique pauvres y aller vous
abonner à leur chaîne le podcast
s'appelle sexe oral s'y est pas déjà
disponibles disponibles éminemment fait
que allez vous abonner à leur chaîne
écoutez leurs podcasts sur l'épaule
regretter ça va être de la vraie bombe
on a la chance en fait d'avoir déjà
écouté plusieurs de leurs épisodes puis
pauvres et s'il a vraiment bon on sait
le but c'est d'en parler de manière
décomplexée de manière vraiment ouverte
vous allez rire vous allez ouellette a
des histoires vous allez apprendre aussi
de quel prix et spécialistes qui
viennent parler de sujets plus pointus
c'est vraiment cool c'est vraiment mais
s'est fait dans la bonne humeur
- et dans la légèreté exact fake abonnez
vous à leurs chaînes abonnez-vous à
notre chine
abonnez vous à toutes les chaînes du
studio sf en fait parce que on crée du
bon contenu que juste part j'ose croire
vous pouvez me donc que sans plus
attendre bon bah de castres bonne écoute
[Musique]
ok c'est parti
bon matin les faits comment ça veut soit
formaté en forme wii effets sont brûlés
en échec face à un être humain est un
merci l'effet d'être là enfin on fait
enfin dans notre spécial slash annonce
de votre nouveau projet pour ceux qui
écoutent de la sans filtre c'est
peut-être quelque chose qui vous
intéressait c'est un podcast que vous
faites ici au studio sf qui s'appelle
sexe oral puis si vous écoutez en ce
moment ça va disponible dans deux jours
je pense d'eux deux jours une semaine à
suivre ensemble par l'espacement
disponible toujours très bientôt
comment comment vous aimez ce faire un
podcast
moi je compare la fin mai mais vous
pouvez vous dire comme l'idée d'abord ça
venait d'où parce qu'ils étaient oui
j'ai vraiment souffert mais c'est votre
en fait l'idéal idée ça venait de faire
un podcast de sexe dans le fond les
autres ça fait longtemps qu'on y pense
bien évidemment pas aux autres l'animal
mais ça fait longtemps qu'on y pense que
c'est un concept qui se fait ailleurs
dans le monde pique au québec et on en
fait pas vraiment puis on s'est dit ah
ben je suis dit oh qui peuvent le faire
parce qu'on n'a pas de personne qui va
venir nous dire de pot farcie en fait
danser ici fait que fait que c'était ça
l'idée on voulait un podcast curieux
quand même un podcast dévergondée sans
complexé en fait sans complexe puis je
pense qu' on a trouvé les deux meilleurs
animatrice pour france on s'est dit
c'est qu'il a versé pas moins gêné qu'on
connaît
lisanne nadeau pour parler de soldado
vie après ce par l'entremise de tourner
à rencontrer mme hervieux juhani wii qui
qui est la personne parfaite pour ce
poste
dont tout seul parce que tu m'as écrit
le bénéfice de faire un live avec elle
sur un stade qu'est ce que la première
fois qu'on se parle et même petits mots
écrits m'a d'abord de trouver une
entraîne qu il m le lendemain matin elle
la seule attaque c'est comme un doux la
fille avec qui il fait rire me semble
qu'ils étaient qu'à la fin on était
remonté jamais arrivé au sud est du
champ contrôler le cash vidéo avec les
gens puis avec elle le sait vraiment
fusionnelle entre eux ont été connectés
il faudrait qu'on se connaissait depuis
tout le temps on se parle et puis on se
promène n'importe quoi vous ne verrez
ouais ouais ça qu'on est tombé ses deux
collègues le monde qui nous écoutent ils
connaissent les armes définitivement
joannie toi ça se peut qu'il y avait
beaucoup de monde qui nous écoutent qui
connaissent pas sur instagram dr point g
non ton compte instagram c'est qu'est ce
que tu fais sur la plateforme pour les
gens qui nous écoutent le et surtout et
je donne des cheveux des vidéos beaucoup
sur les nouveaux produits qui n'est
rentré d'enfants c'est que j'ai une
conseillère en produits érotiques que
développer d'où mon nom une trousse pour
développer le point g de la femme donc
qui moi même je croyais que je n'en
avais pas je pensais que c'était juste
que tori dean et j'ai couvert un secret
puis joly est venue au monde
une boîte et c'est ce que je vais
partout au québec dans toutes les routes
du québec
c'est soit parce que leurs enfants quand
titi conseillère un jouet sexuel que
c'est pour erreur ces compagnies oui
c'est un sex-shop qui est votre
partenaire officiel sur le podcast sexe
oral ouais j'avais que depuis que j'ai
18 ans a fait vite avec ce j'avais
vraiment beaucoup
mac l'indicé plus les femmes et les
couples donc j'aime les femmes à se
découvrir à se développer surtout et à
prendre conscience que leur corps c'est
une machine de plaisir qui se développe
c'est pas juste qu'ils te dire je m'en
collègues du reste non non on peut se
travailler puis l'écho poussé à changer
la routine met du piquant de la
nouveauté
pis j'aime aussi beaucoup aidé les
hommes avec leurs trois stops
c'est un passionné on y reviendra
j'aimerais en apprendre davantage oui
mais attention à la glace pour les
cependant le premier pas de cas soit ce
que vous parlez plus de vous pour vous
présenter ces tirs on ne réalise le
projet mon opposant le chili mettons là
c'est le fun de georges et josé piccioli
mais qui est dans le podcast mur appris
plus sur vos autres le tpiy mais toute
toute une histoire est intéressante
parce que justement au début du plaisir
dans la vie paul non il était petit vous
à l'artiste sur une quête de trouver le
plaisir le pays est devenue la la reine
cuisine séparée de cette façon-là de
votre coming up sur par rapport aux
plaisirs l'exemple c'est le contraire le
mot c'est comme à quatre agents en arrêt
trop
[Rires]
- genre à 87 ou déjà très actives
sexuellement ça commençait pas de
bonheur mon enfant mais bon si ça a été
vraiment long avant que je suis capable
d'avoir un orgasme avec quelqu'un puis
mon point j'ai vraiment clairement pas
aussi développés qualité fait que moi
j'ai peut-être le travail afin de
travailler avec les encarts d'azur c'est
quoi le déclic quand offert giora crise
c'est sûr que ça peut être mettront la
sexualité
ben c'est vraiment belle et le jouet ce
que
que j'ai eu vraiment du plaisir au
niveau régional que comme j'ai dit
tantôt j'en avais pas je faisais l'amour
puis c'est l'heure de la sieste ou
écoutent tous et comme ces bons
qu'estimé dauphine il y en eu le qui
m'écrivent à chaque jour je me fais tout
un cri et joigny j'ai pas d'organe là la
preuve qu'elles sont que je demanderai
aux femmes aux personnes ayant un vagin
c est ce que tu as du plaisir un peu
moyen où beaucoup sont comment moyens je
vais crime cool c'est parfait ça va les
gars tu vois j'ai moi j'en avais paul
geste est vraiment aucunement saint
sébastien une vo la fac e et puis après
tout d'un coup je l' ai découvert c'est
même pas juste ah oui on est déclic
s'est fait mais c'est vraiment un
développement à long terme que j'ai fait
sur mon corps ça que je continue à le
travailler encore aujourd'hui de plein
de façons j'essaie de trouver des
nouvelles choses jeu comme un
scientifique
certains pourraient dire mettons le
selon selon les angles parle puis les
histoires que tintin
et c'est quoi le pourcentage de femmes
qui se retrouvent dans cette situation
là parce que tu dis que tu fait qu'y
puis-je vous dire chers que les
personnes qui se couchent et ça rendait
pas compte
l'annoncé bonne bref c'est quoi une
soixantaine met en place ce qui est bon
signe pour savoir si la personne fait
que je mettais en cas c'est trop genre
comme un acquis non ce postulat ouais je
faisais peur 115 g lb oui vous si jeune
machine andric j'ai souvent de
m'embaucher
mais c'est tout c'est beaucoup pour moi
le fac et si je me regarde avant puis
aujourd'hui clairement les gars je
trouve super de marburg cru ouais fac et
puis aussi comme moi je convie à
l'iphone mais y'a des convulsions qui
c'est le mot carrière mais je pense que
tous les records non mais j'ai comparé à
avancer que j'étais vraiment sexuelles
puis si je paraissais puis aujourd'hui
je fais plus le thé comme si j'en ai pas
et j'en ai pas puis je trouve ça quand
tu viens c'est décontraction je pense le
oui c'est des convulsions pia écoute tu
peux pleurer après la première orgasme
que j'ai eus j'ai pleuré il faut mais
c'est un long chemin c'est un fait
tellement du bien savoir ce que j'ai
commenté orthez ces foules
on peut partir à petit les sens
puis ça dans le fond c'est une fois que
tu te découvre le plaisir de cette façon
là j'imagine qu'après ce téléphone puis
super récompensant pour toi même si pas
un mot de 2
transmettre aux autres mais oui c'est ma
passion ne t il en appelle d'autres
charges portent ce nom c'est gratis
comme pauvres c'est mon bénévoles j'aime
admission cdd toutes les femmes à
découvrir leur corps le projet ce point
j'ai quitté les mamelons est tout petit
j'admire cette foire des messages chaque
jour je répondais mais c'est un message
beaucoup que je le fais le jardin des
étapes je leur donnais de voir à qui il
faut faire tout ça c'est comme ça bon
ben on a envoyé un lien vers notre
podcast c'est sûr parce que j'allais
avoir assez des coups d'odes qui vont
couvrir tous les sujets c'est très toilé
zone de tués depuis le début du podcast
il vous avez 11 épisodes d'enregistrer
est ce que tu as appris des affaires
j'imagine quand même je ne sais pas mais
je suis maintenant le dernier qu'on a
tourné par exemple c'était on a reçu
quelqu'un qui nous a parlé de la
communauté bdsm j'ai appris tellement en
fait c'est juste de sur la communauté
s'est arrêtée ce que j'ai retenu
beaucoup mais ton exemple le drame c'est
que souvent le bdsm on peut associer ce
à la france via la douleur puis il
fallait laisser le billet sinon ça peut
être super doux c'est super je sais pas
si c'est beaucoup une relation de
confiance entre les dominants puisse me
dis c'est pas ça mais ça m'intrigue
baird qui est sûr c'est que ça me permet
de rencontrer des gens et oui tout clip
passe
oui c'est ça parce que dans le fond le
podcast c'est souvent ça va être juste
vous deux
mais aussi vous allez rencontrer des
spécialistes dans certains épisodes sans
vraiment y va un peu de tout en fait je
pense là dedans c'est vraiment cool de
jort que les gens écoutent suppi puisque
je pense vraiment que ça va créer un
genre de jardin de communautés autour de
celui qui va comme à chaque semaine
revenir pierre
apprendre sur sa sexualité quand même
quand même apprendre tellement les a
fait le plus de ce podcast clos c'est
tout ce qu'on veut avant tout comme le
lance in fine c'est la sexualité c'est
tellement large c'est moi je suis
beaucoup pour la pratique télam mais
qu'est ce qu'on apprend le sait on se
masturber ya d'autres choses à vendre de
tout essayer vraiment comme comme commis
dans la dignité et la bdc moi je
honnêtement j'étais vraiment pas au
courant de toutes ces procédés le futur
ce vraiment le fun on apprend autant que
je pense qu'on va aider des gens aussi
je veux qu'on parle aussi éventuellement
de l'absence de sexy doit parler de tout
ce qui est sympa besoin gros crash
muschi concernant sexuellement tout
m'intéresse vraiment heureux de parler
tout seul je pense que chaîne youtube a
reçu ouais j'en ai déjà parlé brièvement
parce que mon petit frère fait son
coming out dans le jeu j'ai appris
récemment qu'à sexuée puis à sexuelle ce
n'est pas la même chose apparemment fait
que je suis payé lequel les deux russes
identifié à quoi mais c'est sûrement
sexuelle et sexiste et comme il n'y
avait pas de genre ses jets de pierres
sexuelle c'est que tu de tempo faire
quelque chose parce que ça me semble si
ce qu'elle avait dit à achraf qui nous
ont pas sexuelles avec lui ça
l'intéresse pas ouais il est juste c'est
comme un grand romantique pitt il veut
vraiment comme tomber amoureux puis
avoir une petite famille tout mais ce
qui concerne avoir une relation sexuelle
il pas du tout et
il n'y a pas de pulsions gens semblent
intéressés puissent est vraiment bonne
valeur pour les filles de sa génération
parce qu'ils coûtent civile venir en
plus nous il m'a dit m
jean l'année passée qui voulait faire un
coming out sur ma chaîne moi je trouve
quelque peu de cas ce serait là mais moi
je frappe et son coming out pour lui ses
poches mais non mais non fram aussi on
parle de tout l'enfant de nofrag d elise
s'ils n'ont pas bien passé mais savoir
les deux temps presque m way mais ils
m'ont frei plus j'ai mis un petit peu je
pense enfin à bombay bombay sa famille
qu'il se trouve vraiment bien de parler
de la prostate par les la prostate par
les la prostate définitivement quelque
chose à explorer en ce qui me concerne
c'est un site expérimental rastatt way
we will et moralement plus j'expérimente
j'expérimente les douanes de famille
doit lé pi bête s'expérimente saout
expérimente avec des partenaires de la
baume est ton ou toit d'autres ceux là
dedans douche me tendre ont expérimenté
dans avec ma partenaire de laboratoire
la quête de la part à toi qui es ce qui
est on est ce que est ce que tu as aimé
ce parce que ce qu'elle avait ouais mais
si ça prend une préparation louis portet
mettant le direct bonne claque
c'est comme dans sa marche bulls à
chicago c'est un gâteau à étages
c'est le pénis est le même temps c'est
la cerise sur gâteau ça qu'on commence
avec moi je commence avec une création
je trouve que c'est mieux parce que tu
commences comme pau à l'intérieur je
n'ai pas grâce à 10h ses camarades avec
lesquels la cuillère à pot en émotion m
l'actrice appréciative au deuxième étage
gâteau au niveau des testicules donc
s'ils vivent en dessous avec talent titi
votre choix la même chose on descend
puis on fait un annulé gus proches à
peille proches le sens saint thélo si
c'est pas quelqu'un qui trouve ça et qui
aimait tant mi-temps situation ouais
legault a essayé ce la fille tous un peu
dégueulasse qu'est ce qu'ils font c'est
faux faux faux à discuter 1
mais moi je pense que pour rien rien de
rien des races que la dent sauf que la
personne savait pas utiliser son doigt
mettons il ya des accessoires pour
remplacer deux et c'est ce qu'on disait
l'autre ça peut être même un petit con
dont un doigt ces sujets mais il y en a
que c'est juste parce que le fait que ce
soit leurs doigts eric sasson dédaigneux
mais ça peut être un accessoire ça peut
jouer qui remplace le doigt ça peut être
un condom sur le doit aussi au quai
ceux-ci j'imagine sont bien prendre
notre douche c'est préférable mais oui
oui oui j'imagine [ __ ] ta douche faut
que tu sois proche en effet pieds acier
quand que des légions pendant la shoah
sur le doigt le met you yet hausse au
dessus de ton doigt sur en poudre pour
patcher la crotte le tas tout d'abord
c'est beaucoup c'est le cas dans le fond
tout ce que tu fais c'est vraiment là en
prie donc lutter fait on a souhaité
qu'un quidam métro aller
[Rires]
belle et s'infiltre mais pas de film
c'est de la santé mentale
oui vraiment habituel annuler un gus
tranquille match puis l'important là
dedans c'est d'abord un super bon leur
chien parce que c'est un lubrifiant à
base d'eau qui sèche qui colle et ça va
être irritant ça va ça va sécher
rapidement ce serait pas agréable donc
moi je conseille un lubrifiant à base de
silicone ou un lubrifiant annales à base
de silicone mais si c'est la même chose
c'est juste qu'ils plus épais qui tu vas
y aller tranquillement juste avec ton
doigt au début factiva à les réinsérer
puis tu vas aller faire un petit crochet
vers var son nom brille par son pénis
puis tué votre inquiets le mans et tu
continues la masturbation ou la création
un bon matin comme on dit mais à qui est
fait mais qu'est ce qui se passe mais
ton pourquoi pourquoi c'est le fun c'est
un rasta c'est prouvé que le maire
orgasme de l'homme m au niveau de la
prostate son orgasme est plus fort et
plus long et plus gros c'est tout les
enjeux du temps et tout les hommes
méritent de connaître sur les galets du
gondwana culte suite de ton expérience
mettons le te tue un orgasme avec à
partir de la prostate bâti est ce que
j'ai lu leurs gaz à partir d'adressés
peau comme valence c'est un ccc long
avant avant d'avoir un orgasme juste la
prostate le cancer et d'autres
oui il ya des hommes oui je n'ai pas
bougé jeu
ce serait très long terme c'est la
décontraction et iliad il ya des hommes
ou des personnes ayant prostate qui ont
des orgasmes juste avec leur contraction
qui sont capables d'aller stimuler leur
prostate avec leur contraction plus
d'avoir un orgasme se soigne avec ta
partenaire c'est elle qui avait amené ce
genre café de savants pis je pense et
moi ouais c'est bon j'ai la même date et
renault est évident qu'elles doivent
être solides dans deux chapelles quelque
chose quand c'est plus facile me tombe
sous les versions à cause de l'eau à
moins que ce système lubrifiants mais je
serai à cause de l'eau d'un faux ça
glisse - puis une faute violente le port
boyer viennent étudier les trucs exemple
vit ses autres qualités bien sûr fait à
l'aise parce que j'ai un cours d'un
petit garçon qui aimait beaucoup celui
qui me guidait là dedans parce que moi
je sais j'avais j'avais déjà comme mais
jamais trop c'est un divorce est pas
trop en confiance et qu'on fait morgan a
fait quoi
c'est juste de faire comme si j'ai vu
ici à quelqu'un tu as mal puis à quel
point footeux loin émeutes ont cessé à
l'entrée vous pas de loin le nom reste
pour sa technique le fait aussi que tu
as été peau et messieurs à 100% c'est
normal parce que ton laisser aller
souvent les personnes c'est leur blocage
et un blocage psychologique c'est game
over
le faux-pas faut juste se laisser aller
qui profite et puis des gardes je peux
avoir du plaisir à ce niveau là je peux
avoir meilleurs orgasmes pourquoi pas
fax et d'être laissée aller puis deux
pas de contracter parce que seafrance et
se plissent contracte pilot baisse à ça
ça fait mal c'est pas agréable faut être
vraiment détendue pu sauver ça se fait
pas à la première fois c'est un peu
comme le point g est la sema sauvage nab
et les finitions ne pas contracter be
sont stressés bain et c'est sûr que on
arpente président fait que ça ça se fait
en plusieurs fois depuis juin signe que
plus de filles qui est gris qui tu
écrives oui il ya des gars puis c'est
quoi les questions c'est quoi les
questionnements les les conseils qui
demande le plus souvent maintenant c'est
souvent au messie fin ils veulent avoir
des masses au batteur parce que je parle
souvent masturbatoire dans mes vidéos
fac les sauces et des sextoys pour go -
il veut laisser ce jeu français
intrigant la prostate j'en ai qui
m'écrivent d'un fois mais pas c'est pas
ma plus grosse crainte et s'il se sent
vraiment les hommes qui veulent explorer
les [ __ ] parce que je pense
qu'ils sont tannés de leurs mains puis
qui veulent essayer jour d'eau ou des
conseils pour leurs copines au soja
monsieur moi les gars qui vient de créer
pour leur copie parce que dès la
première phrase que je dis c'est je
t'aime
bravo ça c'est en témoignent deux rives
qui te mettant à qui tu es ce que me
temps pour leurs copines c'est ma copine
à le devenir
chanson my pillow b c'est sûr que je
peux pas l'aider lui c'est je veux la
jouer des forêts que ta blonde à
m'écrire parce que c'est sa part d'elle
oui je oui je peux te donner des trucs
toi mais si elle je parle peau
puisqu'elle a à se laisse pas aller puis
calais quelque chose c'est ça ça
fonctionne peut-être pour juste une
commune aux combinaisons de
psychologique et physique
c'est quelque chose de physique kiki
bonnes affaires mais où serait puisque
le jury puisque les excès vraiment les
matrices le c'était quatre étapes puis
s'est créé une association entre la
détente de ton corps ton esprit plaisir
que c'est pau c'est pas un produit que
je te dis enfin voici le prix le prix de
la baguette magique python un orgasme
jamais jamais jamais je veux c'est des
étapes que tu répètes une fois par
semaine deux communes genre de
prescription puisque les étapes et le
faut par semaine pour puis moi j'aime
suivre les fils adam dans la révolution
puis si ça fonctionne pas belles à ce
moment là des fois c'est peut-être dû à
un blocage psychologique fait que je les
ai faits
un sexologue disco thérapeute un point
qui semble revenir dans le métro quand
on parle de sexualité si le laisser
aller parce que j'ai l'impression c'est
quelque chose qui retient vraiment
beaucoup de monde mais maintenant on dit
juste de ma propre expérience je pense
si je parle d'éjaculation féminine mais
ton de ma propre expérience les fois où
est-ce que ça ça le marché c'était
kadhafi à se laisser juste à l'islam il
y avait un petit revenu ça marchait pas
de cépie comme si quand même des bonnes
statistiques le t2 de fiction capable
d'éjaculer en fait je sais pas si c'est
100% aussi sylvie jamais entendu genre
80e' pour ça moi j'ai tout ils peuvent
et jacques eu les c
c'est toutes les filles peuvent
véhiculer c'est pour ça qu'on peut te
d'éjaculer c'est quelque chose que est
ce que tu veut le développer ou portez
pas obligé c'est ce ça se peut qu'il y
ait des femmes se regarde on voit des
orgasmes saint jacut les il y en a
d'autres qui vont effectuer sans avoir
d'orgasmes et moi sur ce plat terrain du
palais où je vois tout de mon lit paris
mais ça arrive moi c'est comme la casse
est passée se met ça petit le regarde
plus fort de ma vie même salaire
mon rôle c'est à chaque fois non c'est
que moi c'est que j'ai réussi ce jeu
travers mon corps beaucoup avec mon but
c'est d'essayer d'avoir un orgasme en
même temps déjà qu les tacles mon regard
de ces deux là c'est la pratique le
pauvre est jugé sérieux les bras cette
brosse à la découverte de jeunes ne
m'accepte brahim est produit par la
couleur du pelage tu fasses avait
jusqu'à quatre litres de liquides
corporels car il a joué longtemps code
promo là dessus l'asie est oui anne à
ces malades c'est fascinant qu'est ce
que je suis coupable de jamais m'être
assez informés par rapport à sexualité
toutes les diverses pratiques l'été je
dois je commence le match va nous
écouter
non mais c'est sûr et certain il ne
s'était pas ce n'est pas une blague est
une priorité
j'imagine j'arrêterai tout à fait du
rhône est rude mais je pense que c'est
peut-être plus un réflexe pour les faits
de gloire bien de devoir s'informer
parce que c'est peut-être plus dur pour
nous connecter à notre corps quelqu'un
qui est capable de venir plus instinctif
qui est bon tout est beau c'est sûr
qu'ils étaient peut-être moins le
réflexe de voir mais c'est informer le
fait que c'est juste c'est si le gossip
il s'est posé il ya beaucoup de couples
ils s'épaulent que sa blonde dans le thé
à l'epo même du plaisir avec lui parce
que ça non plus c'est pas important où
je suis autant des autres puis ça reste
dans ma vie mais c'est une question
j'avais justement je pense qu'il ya le
plein de coups parce que ça fait sa pub
avec le tarn et ont peut-être de moins
en moins une des relations sexuelles
c'est comme ça devient ce la norme ça
devient un peu dans le non-dit ou qui se
battent à bout de jardin parler de ce
pilot mettons aussi honey 2 veut aborder
ce sujet là day tripper qu'on devrait
c'est travailler ce pileux
c'est super ça peut facilement devenir
une source de conflits metal cpie pitié
je pense que mettons une relation qu'une
personne soit ça peut être de plus en
plus son expérience des affaires où
justement des plus en plus sa réponse
quand dans ce qu'on connaît on veut pas
trop explorer puis spitz et mettons
aussi après 4,1 thé avec quelqu'un tu
amènes nouvelle affaire où tu dia
j'aimerais c'est peut-être plus de même
je me disais qu'on fasse plus te laisser
coi depuis des plus j'avais 3 ans qui
est insatisfaite ou la fatigue le plus
longtemps tu en parles pas le plus gros
l'éléphant dans la pièce devient goity
les plus durs vient décider si de
nouvelles affaires je pense que tu
commences à madame comment l'âme doit
maintenant quels conseils donneriez à
quelqu'un dans cette situation où nous
habitons ben belize enfin donner un
second conseil
c'était t'avais dit et à conserver les
fantasmes et houleux de demander à la
personne c'est quoi toi qu'est-ce qu'est
ce que tu aimerais qu est ce que tu
aimerais avant de dire et moi j'aimerais
ceux de demander à la personne et après
ce but c'est ce que votre mandat
j'ai l'impression que ça arrive un petit
mouton mettons qu'on prend l'exemple
d'un coup que ça fait quatre ans qu'ils
sont ensemble puis de drag et quelles
sont les démarches que je peux faire
pour raviver notre sexualité j'ai
l'impression que ça arrive un petit peu
comme un cheveu ça assure d'arriver à
l'autre fort qu'eux mais j'ai quand on
joue le jeu sexton mais même mais même
type de demande et les fantasmes comme
ayant un tchèque c'est que ces coûts des
fantasmes approchaient d'une lumière
bleue c'est comme pourquoi tu veux me
dire que je pense que comme angèle amène
rire mais en même temps premiers
seraient pas pour du cash mais c'est
normal j'ai jamais été très longtemps
coupe je pense que j'amène rem et on
leur que ce après quatre ans le taux
jamais utilisé de la saisir de
chandelles gens ben je pense que je
ferai quelque chose pour la personne qui
a rappelé quelque chose de nouveau mais
pour cette personne ne fait qu c'est pas
comme si tu avais un besoin qui m'a
inquiété ces gens parce que tu veux
rajouter quelque chose qui peut plaire à
l'autre
venu je sais pas la meilleure façon
d'inclure les produits retriever c'est
en effet en le faisant vivre à lui une
expérience parce que ce soit n'y fit au
monde je ne veux pas que je sais des
vibrateurs veut pas que je sais si je
pars fait à ce moment là on va pas on va
pas y aller avec toi on va y aller avec
lui avant comme si dit on lui fait
découvrir à lui que c'est des produits
ça peut être le fun ça va pas tu
remplaces et toi c'est cela par tout le
temps ils n'ont pas que grâce à ça va le
remplacer lui a claqué on va lui faire
découvrir à lui ont valu faire une
expérience c'est le ya des scénarios
tels que je propose tout le temps puis
après ce bain live aux tripes et puis
après ça on reprend en tranquillement
fait légaux qu'ils disent ma blonde je
t'invite vibratoire leur besoin de moi
les wii
mais bon c'est quand les beaux malaise
sur ce amener son fils y construire un
fond dans lego sur l'effort humain et
steed groupe d de tourner dans le film
martha mccabe tient à sable entre les
deux les regards se tournent vers gilles
lebreton ces gens c'est quoi ça c'est à
moi j'ai créé la grosse curieuse
d'affaires annoncé un tabou j'imagine je
commence pas si tu commences post trade
up en des tchèques j'achète un
strapontin
ça fait quatre ans que vous faites les
missionnaires trois noms annoncés alors
que de béton la relation comme qui a été
le plus expérimental mettons le chat
commet moi j'adore là je peux qu elle
raconte l'histoire avec monsieur était
peut-être que vous allez c'est quand
vous avez quitté c'est que cela vous
allez entendre demain tu cesses
interviennent nouveautés l'aide
je sais quoi raconter je sais pour qui
via lié tranquillement tgv y avait tout
en quoi de nouveau il avait tout le
temps une nouvelle surprise ou pitt et
surprise ça peut être juste une nouvelle
façon de flatter l'autiste et jc juste
d'être tout le temps comme j'arrivais
prix émérites bougies que le nouvelle
chandelle qui avait acheté précisément
cette journée là pour que ça sent
différent c'était comme toute l'année
mais si c'est quand même
méticuleux travail ce cénacle avons
imaginé à la grèce
à l'affiché j'imagine mal tellement
c'est le goût de fifty mettons il me
faisait une faisant manger quelque chose
de pas trop lourd pour que je me sens
bien fait et après s'il y avait les
bougies pilote du planeur lui c'est sa
plus grande passion briques mais le pape
reste aucun connais bien puisque c'est
là il m'a mené à la chambre qu'il y
avait installé quelque chose s'il y
avait les trucs sur les livres je me
couchais plus le mettais un truc liste
il a eu le champ des le petit messi
comme à chaque fois un moment donné
c'était comme une longue soirée où mme
avait prévu un massage puis comme si ces
gens si tout le temps un peu d'ordre à
kin parce que tu sais pas qu'est ce qui
va arriver c'est tout le temps que toute
l'équipe et le tout était bien il est
tombé c'est la bonne personne pour genre
ouais toutes les filles tout à fait tout
et j aimerais ça c'est d'essayer de la
tension c'est du temps que tu mets une
personne même s'il en est que des gens
non moi je me suis juste souri puis que
ça soit rapide impossible que tempo se
disant les actions dès que ces deux
affaires différentes pour moi le pied on
dirait que tu comme tout les la
procédure autour de d'une relation
sexuelle ou est-ce qu'on explore la
sexualité pied de l'autre côté apprécié
on dirait que l'acte sexuel mettant une
petite vite suce a su le coin parce
qu'elle est en vie ils les deux
départements notre nation comme
consensuel mais on dirait que ces deux
affaires tellement différente des
affaires opposé au soudan le spectre la
sexualité
oui oui le massage chanter sans faire
des tee-shirts
mais au fait qu'est - ce que je
conseille c'est juste racheté une petite
affaire pour l'eau mais j'avoue qu'ils
aiment et ont amené de même si mettons
que je thomas team et ont tout fait mme
dati mettons un point une ville histoire
une histoire d'un gars qui nous écoutent
dans ce moment qui se dit le moi
j'aimerais ça fait cinquante ans que sa
blonde il couche avec une fois par deux
semaines ça lui convient peau il
aimerait se faire de quoi
au lieu de dire plus d'amener ceux du
genre j'aimerais sociaux a mené ce dans
son genre qu'est ce qu'on doit faire que
toi je pense qu'il m'aime pas je te fais
je te regarde toi je pense à toi
de ce fait je me suis fait deux fois le
genre
une fois le québec non répond une fois
le mondial après que la première fois je
retrouve ma rappelé
ben est là aujourd'hui c'est ton plaisir
à toi je te fin de soirée pour toi je ne
veux riz et écoute la pression le
matelas la chute de pression qui fait
comme un fort match aller se sont
habitués quand je reçois je dois donner
j'ai toujours été sur toute ma vie ces
montures en ce moment cette personne
lopy et pour mourinho tige
c'est fou ce parce qu'on dirait que
cette dynamique là de donner pour
recevoir c'est comme dynamique qui
quittent inculquer probablement à
travers la pornographie ou est-ce que
tout le temps la même séquence
d'évènements de type cloud comme les one
man se ressemblent parce que tout le
monde a vu la même pour tout le monde
fait la même échanges de services entre
guillemets alors que c'est pas vraiment
ça mais en même temps les deux parties
veulent du plaisir géraldine on s'est
souvent je donne pour l'heure la
dynamique est donnée de te donner parce
que moi je donne ces reflets slip et
cinq ans moi je donne puis je m'attends
à rien à y gagner
jackpot il m'a gagné ce n'était pas mon
travail est de 500 avec mon vélo pour
rien de plus puis une soirée qui m'a
mené à l'automne un hôtel puis stéphane
soir y avait mis les attachant du
matelot parce que moi j'ai eu une
connaissez le il savait dans quoi je
travaille faq y avait quand même
beaucoup de pression il ya des gens
qu'il faut faut chasser des quelque
chose 2008 avant c'est aussi le
basketteur et là dedans c'est qu'ils
connaissent eux puis 2 2 2 4 2 diamant
les attaquants marseillais y avait mis
les attachant tim hatley il m'avait
coucher 2000 bardot et il m'a attaché
puis dit le ceo qui me dit josette
asseoir et se laisse aller je veux rien
juste speed mais ne s'était pas
d'orgasme sociaux à mon dieu c'est celle
ci n'a pas dit comment tout de suite en
or guère ce genre de seconde s'est fait
poser question 12 fois le pape est venu
jouer ce week end 4 n'ont pas posé
jamais posé cette question le petit pot
c'est pas grave j'ai même pas vu cette
soirée lui je pense j'avais même pas eu
d'orgasme j'avais eu un orgasme
corporelle et émotionnel dit et sur tout
mon corps que je le vivais ce texte et
muse
c'était plus grohl j'ai jamais vécu ce
parce que le laisser-aller que avec un
homme parce que j'étais j'étais rendu
capable tout seul mais avec un homme
j'avais jamais réussi puis cesser sa
phrase du début qui me dit fais que le
truc utilisé le juste prévoir une soirée
pour madame lui faire découvrir et c'est
ce que demandent les mêmes quelque chose
que je veux souligner que dit le c'est
de se faire dire comme et comment tu te
sourit c'est asseoir des soins qui a dit
le genre comme je ne viens pas tant que
toi tu viens pas au genre je ne reçois
rien tant que toi topo reçu le way c'est
comme tu dis le la première fois qu'ils
s'étaient fait jour se rappelle tout à
vimont si même en faire la première fois
que je suis venu avec quelqu un bon pot
par pénétration par wever c'était juste
moi qui se touchait à côté de quelqu'un
je seul mais j'avais jamais été capable
de me laisser arripe de montrer de quoi
j'avais de l'argent non la première fois
c'était mon ex qui me dit bon le genre
aujourd'hui c'est juste un moyen qui ce
passe temps que trois jambes qui on
dirait que ça m'a donné la permission de
le faire ça m'a donné la permission de
mettre l'énergie sur moi sur juste de ma
tête au lieu de focus et sur lui de
focaliser sur moi qui joue seul ça a été
comme ça ça m'a ouvert une porte mais
juste de donner ça sonne un peu niaiseux
mais de donner la permission la partie
r de se concentrer sur elle-même c'est
une folle folle important parce que ça
faisait comme qui on donne pour recevoir
un peu mais j'ai l'impression est
peut-être mais un stéréotype mais j'ai
l'impression que la fia va plus souvent
passer à l'autre partout en mettant des
contexte sexuel mettant avant suscité
comme dit en mode comment je peux y
faire plaisir le plus que sais je sur
plusieurs points comme un piège près
archers monde où le plus le plus cru
possible testait pas genre je pense à
moi comme un objet defence était de quoi
j'ai l'air
qu'est ce que je vais ressentir ça mais
maintenant avec du recul comme même si
les chinois qiu même si comme je prends
moins le temps d'avoir l'air de quelque
chose change c'est encore plus comme
cochons parce que c'est un christ deux
côtés de l'arpp qu'ils laissent tomber
toutes les variables et jusqu'à demain
petits monstres les allées c'est ouais
passionnant si bout c'est beau mais un
que s'ébauche est nécessaire non pas de
casser ça mais non mais si c'est la
condition qu'on a pu tantôt c'est ce qui
vous êtes pareils l'entraînement que sur
les podcasts j'ai tellement hâte que les
gens l'écoutent de vraiment je pense
vraiment que ça va ça va rejoindre
classement du monde pas pour rejoindre
bah ce bassin même si ça risque d'en
rejoindre un vaste mais ça risque de
rejoindre profondément les gens c'est
ultra intéressant puis au delà de jeu
des discussions comme ça autour de
certains sujets il ya certes un autre
concept dans votre podcast je trouve
quand même intéressant à bord d un
concept qui est autre que les gens vont
pouvoir voir très prochainement sait où
est ce qu'on rend conclusion je m'exclus
voit ce qu'on rencontre les les
personnes qui ont été dans notre passé
sexuel puis souvent sans avoir jamais
reparlé on donne l'exemple de keven
parce que keaven lapierre qui a fait
deux fours dit tu as eu des relations
sexuelles avec lui
pis si vous en avez pas vraiment
reparler plus vous l'avais invité pour
reparler de tout un peu moi je trouve ça
fascinant ce concept là de revoir des
gens parce qu on a tous un grand succès
avec des personnes on a tous je mange
une grande majorité des gens c'est que
c'est avec des personnes sans jamais
n'en parlait même si on n'est pas en
mauvais termes ont même si sap s'est
bien terminée puis la perception de
cette union sexuelle doit être tellement
différente d'une personne à l'autre
s'il faut qu'on en parle jamais c'est
fou qu'on n'en parle jamais magie mais
je te mettais beaucoup loin de mettre
dans ma ville j'en ai peut être cinq ou
six mettons le poignet une poignée et
des voix moi je suis comme un pingouin
hier matin non moi je fréquente déjà
fréquenté trois mois c'est sûr mais même
chose pour moi c'est arrivé une fois
qu'on sait pas vraiment parler à part
peut-être croisé puis dire salut
maintenant l'instar des cinq ou six fois
pittis monde le même si je somme toute
cordiales avec eux quand les voies
c'est sûr que notre perception de la
soirée était différente
c'est sûr que si on s'arrêtait parler
avant si on s'était parlé de nos
attentes si on s'était parlé de qu'est
ce qu'on aimait qu'est ce qu'on aimait
pas ici on se tait reparlait après
peut-être qu'on aurait recruté ensemble
ça aurait été 10 fois mieux parce que
max ait jamais l'optimal mai mais ce
concept mais vraiment je trouve qu'ils
voulaient fait avec heaven qu'est ce qui
en est ressorti ne tombe légèrement on
pourra entendre le podcast le dame coupe
de la caf qui ressortent de l'étude et
l'évaluation le tissu appris quelque
chose et c'est quelque chose que j'aime
et ont une perception que tout avis qui
finalement c'est quelque chose que non
je pense bernard cup qui vend depuis moi
on était quand même un cycle de deux
personnes qui communiquent je pense je
la sais moi ce qui est sorti surtout
c'est qu'on était sous toulon les deux
camps parce que moi je m'en souviens
semis mais je me souviens qu'on avait en
fait on en parlais ils me raconter ça
fonctionnait assez bien de genre tout
les détails memoir by samsung cheikh
hamad avait eu un orgasme à wez macquart
[Rires]
mais non c'était plaisant parce que
comme une fois que j'arrête de voir
quelqu'un entre je m'en suis plus avec
l'au-delà revoir ses caves à sévrier
peut-être maillot mais je me souvenais
je parle pas de haut niveau sexuel on ne
porte chance à vous je parlais justement
flavio pdc dans cette drôle puis gévry
la marque que ce soit au tour de joe a
mis ma vie - ou alors j'ai écrit à
quelqu'un j écris moi méthodes qu'ils
veulent c'est une personnalité quand
même public rac lui c'est dérange pas là
mais moi je pense pas qu'il ya d'autres
personnalités publiques qui vont avec
les piliers faudrait choc mon répertoire
là mais comme j'en sais la boucle mon
scrabble n'est pas beaucoup mais non
plus le meilleur 2 1 je sais pas ce que
lui tu sais que j'ai écrit que c'est
vraiment c'est pas sa faute ce soir
c'est que sexuel piste et comme c'était
quand même bien taper sur les nerfs mais
ce qui est sûr j'imagine que c'était
aussi gênant pour est présent mais bien
d'autres
je pense en fait je pense pas qu'il y en
ait que joannie y avait en plus on avait
essayé mon fameux la première fois
j'avais seiji pop avec quelqu'un c'est
avec lui puis quand il voulait le garder
le jeu comme nom du tout fâché non non
non qu'est ce que la wii et de mehdi
j'en veux un
c'est ça fonctionne trop c'est trop de
malades icap hôtesses le jeep au kiosque
l'époque mais c'est ma tiges l'eau et
des litiges avec deux boulots boon qui a
peut-être ce que ça te faisais à toi -
keita qui voulait en avoir un aspect qui
a porté sur son capot tpiy avait chargé
le bain c'est que c'est vraiment joué
que tu vois c'est une petite boule que
tu mens herrera du vagin est souvent
allé cogner sur le point g mais c'est
tellement mieux connu par les connaît
ouais tu vas à l'etap hôtel bordeaux
dame est rien mais c'est vraiment quand
vous dites qu il mettait comme à lyon
qu'ils et plus tu vas le faire
rapidement
plus un mot il s'ajoute s'agissait juste
de samui samui c'est juste magique la
danse de séoul est juste que tu m'aimes
just a même fait ça empêche le programme
que j'ai trouvé mon expérience à la
recherche des points j'ai c'est que je
pense des crânes des mains du peuple
après ça c'était pour ce parce que lui
avait été celle du web
barnes et l'onf un gonfleur poing géant
qui est déjà pas gonfler un point c'est
que ces forfaits gonflé yg en plus du
single plus à gauche parce qu'un point g
sekito rice sauf que c'est de l'intérêt
[Rires]
fac le point mais c'est quelque chose
que c'est la première fois que j'entends
parler de faire gonfler ouais ben c'est
qui au début d'une relation souvent
les filles ont maintenant qu'on en fait
pas combien de points gmail à projets -
et c'est tout le temps par la fin de la
relation qu'on recommence et du plaisir
c'est à cause de ce que le point g est
gonflé tranquillement fait que si tu le
fais conflit au début de sa relation au
début de factures stimule
mais steven frossard plus de plaisir
taclé dit popp
ben c'est un jouet qui va te permettre
de faire gonfler son point g fac tu peux
le faire avant de faire l'amour comme
préliminaire un peu comme les doigts les
facs les doigts quand tu peins série
plus vous gonflez plus va le sentir
messieurs c'est quelque chose c'est ce
qui se développe le mois mettant mon
point g aujourd'hui je fais juste mettre
mon doigt ce après même pas une minute
puis je me sens encore il s'est passé il
sait les ja idées sans suite je bouffe
ça gonfle tranquillement et dans le fond
une bonne stratégie se seraient deux
femmes dont fit le point g avant qu'ils
aillent pénétration des jo ce j'imagine
que c'est un peu un gâteau à étages au
steel wheels ans que tu rentres poule j
pop art commence à la main en effet
gâteau à étages c'est sûr foutiez à
trinquer mathy simule le clitoris
externe en premier ni apprécié eux mêmes
difficiles mais tu peux aller masse et
moi j'ai tout le temps avant si tu es
capable pour certaines souris le sait la
relaxation avant la pénétration est
toujours facon relaxe le corps au début
on relaxe esprits puis apprécier aussi
me lectrices puis à pression et vos
nouveaux vaginale tranquillement nouveau
du point g pour le stimule on le fait
gonfler puis après ça on veut insérer
que depuis que nous rejoignions hutch
expérimenté plus avec ton point g
qu'avant à chaque fois je fais comme un
jour georges enlève la fac et pour
stimuler mon point j'ai pas mon enfant
pour mon cas c'est ce que c'est sur ces
cas
mais si ce que tu dis le moi c'est ma
relation que la masturbation
maintenant l'acte de masturber ça me
fait chier parce que chicken du regard
de la pointe ça me fend le cul parce que
ces deux-là point le tc jamais jamais go
et clips le l'éclairage est pauvre c'est
gentil s'est calmé les 200 photos et
moyens les accords sont les personnages
et règle ses motivations restent il y en
a qu'un seul mint équipe astronautes à
cologne n'est pas bien ce que ça prend
des poses meiway affecté moi c'est comme
je le ça finisse témoin comme le
processus n'a d'égal que la femme est un
gage par le mass market apprennent à
faire l'amour j'ai pas envie nouvelle
phase doit avoir un éveil sais comment
c'est vrai que c'est tellement de stock
pour comme ça dit il
pour sam genders amgen pop à tous tout
seul chez nous ils rien qui me gène le
méné joseph ici on dirait que c'est
tellement d'efforts pour au final c'est
moins d'efforts que tu penses une fois
que le doigt le toit mais maintenant le
set up le thé mais le franc reculait je
m'installe
si je me mets du lou pitt avait
possiblement que va prendre une douche
après tu sais quand je trouve qu'ici je
tousse et comme beaucoup de procès se
soit originellement à chaque fois tu
sais c'est attend éponyme ben oui je
serve avant tout à jour n'est quand même
pas pourquoi le loup n'y est pas chaque
fois que tu passes ton blog tu crois que
tu es comme moyen hommes et femmes
questionnements ou hockey tout en art
garçons jours tout est pareil il va et
essais sur les orgas c'est pô juste
éjaculer ça peut être corporel ça peut
être émotionnel pas que c'est ce qu'il
faut qu'on découvre l'être humain ça
qu'elle a pas tant que genre je veux
sentir une vue d'ensemble je vais
attendre et knox à des largages
oui quelques incidents le titre qui
parle de travail sur ton corps parce que
dans le fond j'imagine que le travail le
travail majine oui ce n'est pas tout ce
travail doit se faire tout seul d'une
partie travail ce soir un couple gay
cela mais comme vous les gosses et ceux
ci voulaient avant de l'essayer qu'une
fille moi je pense s'est mis tout seul
tu veux savoir plus qu'est ce que ça
fait et puis tu vas être moins stressé
dessus va plus savoir à quoi que de
satan mais moi je pense que c'est
commencé tout seul avec son corps puis
après ceux de la mener tranquillement
dans ta relation doit être capable c'est
comment tu demander à quelqu'un de faire
du plaisir si toi même tu es pour garder
tant donné je remets ça c'est plus pour
les îles et les femmes en général il y
en a beaucoup lutté qui me dit j'ai pas
d'orgasme et mais est-ce que tu fasses
ou parce que tu touches non mais si on
va commencer à la base dont jamie paulo
ont tranquillement au bail
c'est coûteux vu une sexologue là au
début quand beaucoup pire c'est quoi
maintenant les grandes lignes de ce
qu'on parle de [ __ ] toul
ouais mais c'est ce que j'ai vu beaucoup
c'est ce beaucoup de sexologues
finalement c'est finalement sexuelle
discuter rapport c'est ce que
les personnes moi j'avais un blocage
psychologique qui fixe et c'est là que
et les musicothérapeutes l avons essayé
très vite on blocage enlever des housses
apporter sa part de quand j'étais un peu
je me suis pas senti comme un objet rare
is home c'est de donner du physique moi
je m'en foutais même si c'est pas normal
c'est je mérite pas ce jeu mérite mieux
puis j'ai droit d'avoir du plaisir mon
style et ça a été long avant que je le
réalise
puis c'est avec cette personne là qui
qui me fait réaliser ce que je joue pour
ça que je laime dans mon fils est il que
j'aurais fait rire tout le monde tout le
temps elle a aidé vraiment à me
découvrir moi savoir que j'ai le droit
d'avoir dû poser puis que je mérite
pickeu sais pas si ça a tout changé ma
perception noté j'avais plein de je te
demandais des règles des groupes c'est
juste leur plaisait et puis moi je m'en
foutais mon plaisir c'est de donner du
plaisir mais crime non là c'est là
aujourd'hui clairement c'est plutôt le
hockey c'est où il ya des fois où est ce
que je veux donner du plaisir à mon
homme uniquement puisque chose
importante c'est juste qu'on disait
tantôt d'un fois des soirées uniquement
pour lui
des fois juste des soirées pour moi mais
des fois des soirées en coupe mais je
suis jamais au cas pas capable de me
laisser autant aller si je pense à son
plaisir ccim et on se dit poga qui
aspire cette assurer ma soirée le groupe
les et que j'essaie quand c'est ma
soirée à moi avec ma couverture à cheval
que je parle y recourir aux lacs se
montrent jamais mis la découverte du
côté rosset
c'est mon plaisir à moi ok vous fait
interner votre taux un genre de son
orient sourire mon chalet ferrari
faisait travailler chez qu'une grosse
semaine je vais faire plaisir à qui y
arrivent dans charme puis l'a couverte
un côté bleu et quand il se garroche
olivier comme vous
quand ces femmes c'est la petite sarah
poil décollement myo rien qu'au des
bleus le cantal le monde sont élaborés
je triple c'est pas juste quelque chose
qui absorbe c'est une signification
qu'on lui a donné ça évite une coupe
deux brassées de lavage et on avance
doucement des serviettes mais ça passe à
travers les services mais faire l'amour
sur ton lit de la surcote moi je mets
tout le temps à couverte quasiment
toutes à menin mais si on en ayant mis
en eux aussi une couverture qui fait
qu'ils quincy stéphane aggrolites
premier league cellules non c'est un bon
atout avoir lisant ton batman du sexe
qui dormait sur le même lit
excellent même l'y attend un livre est
emprunté la somme de chantereine j'avais
des souvenirs de ce que ça sentait chez
nous dit qu'il faut mettre le cap sur le
bien-être est partie la soirée c'est pas
dégueulasse et plus payer les trophées
sont les aisselles cfoot à la panne n'a
pas de casque genre c'était comme i 3 et
les aisselles puis sortait de la douche
puis c'est comme mes cd ou le navet 1
chez nous pourtant qu'il est chez nous
tel défaut la tension dans les ca et de
ce goal com ans non mais t'es foutu
quand est ce qu est ce qui le fait
triper way pour savoir ce sacré gens je
sais pas comment inscrire sais je sais
que ça peut avoir un peu oublieux de vue
de l'extérieur parce que je regarde dans
n'importe quel autre la sonde juno ma
vie j'ai ramené ce même processus
l'américain boeing d'arrêter fois king
georges landry
je sais pas c'est comme tu es tout l'été
comme précieux bilan actuel
ouais c'est ce tout et retient un masque
vous chantiez du genre de chant
grégorien
vous a bâti janvier quand même cher ça
va être un peu ça avec ton copain mais
moins brasse pommettes en même temps
j'aimerais enfin on nous notre notre
site c'est qu'à chaque mois on se
prendrait pour nous pour faire quelque
chose de différent avec un peu tu sais
comme toi le vouvoyer faisait quelque
chose de différent avec nous on ajoute
un nouveau jouet est des fois c'est même
poète quand on joue b.to nu puis c'est
juste on fait quelque chose de différent
on n'est pas de cellulaire puis on se
donne une soirée à nous de pire en fait
quelque chose de différent
enfin vous autres mettons des fois tu as
l'argent et dole c'est comme ce sourire
la soirée une fois pas moi c'est les
prix vu le signal qui montre jamais j'en
ai voyagé on avait quelque chose d'autre
non c'est notre soirée à nous et puis
parce que si tu mets pas dans l'agenda
de jeffrey papier ça fait vraiment du
bien
et une fois par mois le moi je dis
maximum deux mois
c'est fait les toutes les coupes
prennent est une soirée pour vous pour
le pour les deux fait garder je savais
que les enfants alors je sais que ce ne
sera pas évident à puis je veux pouvoir
en parler je vous pouvez vous comprendre
mais pour moi c'est tout ma guerre des
magasins et déjà prévu une fois par mois
jorge aimait mon enfant comme les n 10
les premiers samedis du mois
géographie pourquoi vous avez
réunion huawei on en fait je peux je
sais ça se peut qu'on fasse mais pas
avant c'est vraiment juste en scène
soirée pour nous est quelque chose de
différent puis on prend du sens pour
nous
avez vous déjà eu ce genre de des petits
rituels avec une fille que c'était
vraiment plus ce matin au stade moueix
moi j'ai été puis je lave ou nul à chier
d'un d'un ne pas perdre la flamme
mettons sur des relations de longue de
l'ombre de long terme j'en ai quelques
jeunes dans ma ville j'ai été un de la
chimie
je dors autant que l'autre personne en
relation mettons le mets salés pas
comment non plus mâché un pot commun ce
n'est pas une priorité pour moi mais
j'ai jamais je me dis que j'ai jamais
rationaliser que c'est important ce
point l'homme et on le
fait qu'ils n'ont fait que moi j'ai
jamais fait si je sais très bien que
j'aurais dû le faire le sait vraiment
mais non non jamais jamais fait ça je
comprends tout bouger monsieur d'amour
il ya la ddt
on est allé ouais bah oui on est fait le
podcast avec thermo 9 accosteront c'est
rare qu'on parle de sexualité mettons
tout mois puis un pouvoir qu'on en parle
ensemble et c'est vrai qu'on en pense le
podcast et puis là on avait reçu
tellement levac planète comme parler du
genre de pointe qui est écouté et kwapis
non mais je ne m'y a juste nommé un
vidéo qui était somme toute relativement
vraiment avec des guillemets en couleurs
des vidéos à l'ats adrian est chez cicc
déjà relativement normal qu'elle fait
qui quand même un temps ce métier qui
somme toute je peux te lâcher qui selon
elles de violences ou des casques des
murs ou des billets mais accueille aussi
sais aussi que je disais mettons que je
regardais soit des vidéos est ce qu'il y
a plus que deux personnes ne tombe pas
je crois à faire piloter morizet mais ça
veut dire qu étiquetage être expérimenté
faute en phase dite somme des orgies de
faire de même
je dis oui ce genre quelque chose que je
ferais plus j'ai déjà fait mes temps
mettez je pourrais me lève pas le matin
il faut absolument pas si on gagne
aujourd'hui besoin que je pense que la
pornographie des affaires que tu sais
que tu regardes mais c'est qu'ici quand
même dans l'ordre des fantasmes
récemment quelque chose que tu veux -
nécessairement va produire six
ouais les fantasmes ce n'est pas fait
pour être réalisés à tous ceux en garde
parce que c'est l'excitation si l'effet
de tout blâme en expliquant sur la mode
un fantasme c'est fait pour imaginer
cette image est en train et stylé suis
fait tout bien et cette excitation le
bon débat je vais les faire de focus sur
les josaphat faut juste pas c'est le feu
jeudi la liste est somme toute quand lee
smolin mettons de chose à faire contre
si tu te rends au bout de la liste de
choses à faire sexuellement
c'est pas parce que c'est ce que les
gens comprennent pose pas parce qu'il ya
quelque chose qui t'excite que tu dois
absolument le faire sauf et ftp le
domaine du bénin le plus choquant mais
ouais mais tu ne ressens pas l'urgence
de comme des swinging pour faire un
leurre gym a tenté pile après un genre
gers des messages à ce que moi puis des
amis
merci mes écouteurs sont à leur tour
cette fois pas fait mais comme cela
m'évitera qu'aux petites et 5 août face
au mal non bonjour je bats je ne pense
pas que tu aies jamais vécu l'expérience
d'un savait qu'il excédait les mecs que
tous deux fini ben ali game - parce que
trop personnes plus que ça commençait à
quatre ça finira trouve maintenant
bailly parti s'est levé le piquet part
si tu vois là non ça va convaincre saleh
fils d'haïti partie pourquoi
ils savaient pas d'acheter vague parce
que parce que sauf que des vrais humains
et qu'ils ouais mon ipad non delorme et
il ya quelqu'un à macul c'était vraiment
utile tout a été verbalisé revint
consentement et compagnie puis quelqu'un
en plein milieu qui se sentent ici et
puis à personne ne s'est levé et a fait
taire je voyais à lépine stabilité c'est
bon du péage de remoulins ocha oui bon
du ps et c'est finalement ça a fini à
trop dans le frigo ou doudounes deux
facs de god de vie puis ça finit avec
toi de vie non à a agréablement surpris
on va tester un fuck mai
mais c'est ce qui est arrivé mais c'est
plus que selon le team mettons le comme
certains vidéo est ce que ce qu'est ce
qu'on dit juste avant que je tombe dans
un petit hameau levac s'il y avait comme
un filon qui était bon mais je sais pas
mais je sais pas pensez vous que la zone
est ce que vous consommez de la deûle à
de la pornographie mettant tout le temps
je n'en ai pas besoin
à chaque fois que je perds ma soeur et
moi je fais j'ai perdu un peu l'intérêt
en main c'est comme quand c'est le
moment de choisir mon vidéo je suis un
peu comme ça j'avais la raquette au
système aussi c'est comme un passage
obligé le coincer ce jeu comme je sais
que je peux revenir plus vite ces gens
regardent je sais que j'en choisis comme
cgg [ __ ] excité parce que je regarde
tu vaux dessus sur les sites mais cette
relation comme beaucoup de gens de
féminité qui maudit tiges pas la porte
sur un homme est quand même plus fait
avec dans le but d'être regardé vers un
public cible masculin je pense lancer
puis c'est vraiment pas je pense toutes
les filles que ça excite justement à
cause que si vraiment axé sur le plaisir
de l'homme
clairement les fake et compagnie le tir
et tout se fait sous 1,36 pour seulement
gens n'écoutent pas beaucoup sur mac os
dessus parce que je trouve pas mon
contrat mais où cité ben chikha j'aime
souci n'est pas écouter un film que
j'achète ce matin aux sections mais qui
une histoire qui que tu achètes le lac à
cette loi plus la date c'est parce qu'il
ya une histoire
les personnages million d'ebooks m
il ya des histoires puis légaux sont
fokine t on voit autant legault que la
fille fax et soeurs pour ce que je pense
que le jeu au pied mais crémont les voit
pas en dhr et puis c'est tout le temps
comme vous le portez sur la fille puis
que j'écoute des films il ya comme deux
petits bonhommes c'est suis coc chamiers
celle-ci yakup facs je sais qu'une
histoire
ça peut être des aventures du soudan
ouais comme le métal à l'histoire de
chez pro - le mari qui rentrent à la
maison au piquet genre et la soeur
sabrina il faut qu'un scénario si c'est
comme trop sur moi c'est ton frère
photographies des gens amateurs
un matin ces fumées dans un parti ça
fait trop en fait mais tu vois moi
souvent je tama je skie pas le début je
dis ce qui bougeait ski pas tout le
temps le denim m6 a présenté le matin
parce que c'est quand j'ai regardé début
j'ai script toutes les milieux avancer
quoi l'ailé
les mâles élément déclencheur la tension
du début puis les gens les premiers
préliminaire moi ce que je fais c'est
que je reviens j'ai ce moment chaque
maison qui viennent trop vite le jeu
reculant il faut tellement terre en même
temps tu viennes en même temps qu'elle
joue vraiment prenante
c'est vraiment pas ça fait pas partie de
mon toutou qui m'avait déjà dit une fois
tir de la pointe s'est quand même genre
une pizza et c'est vraiment quand tu la
regardes dans un moment ou un steak à
m'exciter ça arrête nos jardins resto
italien qui est débile
la seconde où est ce que tu es venu
salades pizzas congelées brûlé dans la
seule qui dégouline
c'est comme dicte aux plus fins la pizza
à pyla bref aucun que je fais mon ordi
vraiment vite après tu vois tu veux ou
tu veux pas savoir comment qui
l'histoire se termine on s'était
samantha repenti qui était être
secrétaire dans une école ça arrive sud
puis il ya des élèves qui étaient tombés
sur des vidéos d'eric faisait de la
peine puis il ya le scénar entendu si ça
m'intéresse a fait que c'est un bon gars
et rodez puis elle s'était secteur d'une
piste en fait tout un à faire céder
comme il le monde c'est comme défaut le
monde sont crissement puritaine petit
comme elle est en contact avec des
enfants nan annoncé par téléphone qui
est près d'être pire que ça faisait au
genre qui avait que les petits guette de
tomber dessus cela c'était elle était
comme agente d'immeuble place des
visites un condo en coupe puis le rôle
finalement en ayant eu et c'est le mat
leur rappeler qu'en séquence a fourré
les trois ensemble sur la fin
le couple le guen se lève type les
abeilles pleut elle est comme tous les
ans lit pas dit avec la vous n'avez pas
le prendre le contrôle
c'est en fait en tabarnak comme le juste
fou réfléchissant laffineur dialogue de
haut niveau qui ont tout misé et
autonomie la préface pour faire genre à
qui ils font vraiment tour du condo lie
à leur montre la cuisine la toile était
à leur montre qu'on d'opi les cochons
ensemble dans l'hyper c'est la finale
c'est comme ils sont dix ans on peut pas
tous faits mais c'est sur ce fond moins
rapide et je n'ai pas de prendre le
condo non non non je te fou c'est que tu
vois ça mix très polar mabhouh était pas
la meilleure production
ça fait des années qu'ils vous de la pop
québécoise de fois bah moi je n'écoute
plus rien à y voir
ça m'arrive d'écouter les noms ça
m'arrive d'écouter pégase production
parce qu'ils ont été entendus
qu'est ce que c'est bon maintenant je
vois plus largement que je suis vraiment
attaché au sac comme drôlement le monde
qui écoute le sans fil doit s'en rend
compte amer a même posé le commentaire
on voit chaque vraiment beaucoup qui
chaque parent explique si je fais
attention pour conserver son âme en
rotation mots parce que je trouve sur
forte et je trouve que c'est plus sain
puis il ya quelque chose d'un l'accent
québécois avec des qualités tabarnak
kimo j'ai très peu
oui mais pas que cela existe et qu'on
dirait que s'il sait on dirait que celle
qui met donc un scotch avec des filles
pickles piqué le mettons leurs rêves
leurs réflexes parce que c'est de la
pointe s'est tourné à l'anglais josh
hill music
je sais pas parce que moi j'ai moi j'ai
jamais sacré ma vie je sac pauline
tabarouette en même temps c'est quoi là
c'est moi moi maintenant le 2 litres que
je laime qu'un québécois peu loin mais
ces droits que tout est ce parce que il
ya une fois qu'il ya une fille qui me
dit mon tabarnak qui genre je pense
encore c'est tellement fort même traiter
quelqu'un mon tabarnak multi ces quatre
saynètes les transmettra son nom le
soutenons mais pas tout à fait à côté
si m c'est le sahara fait le plus une
seule maison soit des classes en moins
et à quatre pattes puis georges servi
pyj lécher le cul l'enfant non j'ai fait
sauter a fait genre voit pas encore je
pense encore c'est encore mon colis
tabarnouche tous cas qui coûte un point
sur deux elle n'écoute jamais mes jambes
tout à fait j'écoutais grâce à moi
j'aimerais vous parler de deux poêles
pas mal payés au parc on parle de ce
qu'on sera le bal des proches mettent en
monotype était comme moi ça parle pas
mal de fois l'at on pas que ça va être
fun segments gants remettre sur
instagram montabard j chez qui j'ai
parlé que tu
notamment à écouter les podcasts c'est
ouais bah écoute à peu près on peut
tenir sur ben évidemment a choisi sa
naïveté des foyers déshérités qui l'a
rejoint de moins que ceux mais ça se
peut qu'elle écoute lui le parce que
j'ai tellement parlé de ce projet le
genre de votre podcast puisqu'elle est
trouve ça super cool j envoyais charlie
c'est parce qu'on a fait
pour la petite histoire le photoshoot
l'est la semaine passée j'ai envoyé
genre les petits déjà quand quelqu'un
qui avait un pré pré montage de fait le
pitre
mais combien de messages de reçus de
monde qui pense et que faisait des
gardiens 1
moi j'allais si on fait des jeux c'est
pas même pourquoi tout le monde décrit
bon le sila moi même le monde un médium
de personnes soient nos médias ce qui me
fait rire les gens doivent maintenant le
lendemain du shooting photo t'annoncer
que temps avec brodeur trépy genre pour
s'amuser djallel le ton shooting de
guadeloupe se dit qu'on a fait ça semble
quand même et puis on l'a fait
distinguer un peu puis le genre de la
maison mais qui vit en moi
pht big brother il dit a voulu avant le
monde décrivait à toi que moi je le
faisais moi
c'est moi qui fais pas de casque mais
non on n'y a personne qui m'a écrit nan
je le ferai si je retournais pas dans
une télé réalité mais sûrement la
précipitera propre expérience de moi
c'est sûr que je ne referai pas même pas
au genre de la star academy maintenant
c'est pas franchement que je ferai une
autre téléréalité man c'est trop citron
et un petit fils a vu ses soutes grands
noms cités pour rodez à l'écrin qui
pillent et à les séparer du sens bien je
suis vraiment vraiment s'assurer le
peuple maintenant je suis vraiment moins
compétitif que j'étais le genre 4,5 m
quand même à ma fibre de compétition
natation maintenant comme et come back
home fait déloger que plus de plus de 2
100 m ce soir deux parties respectent
pas ou ne peut pas tout king
j'ai je sors de comme crever l'abcès lui
dédia l'ipcum pu penser à ce qui s'en
vient juste vivre une seconde fois mais
non je fais je pense à fait juste
c'est quoi le but de l'émission mettons
c'est comme un concept entonnoir le
c'est plein de monde dans une maison qui
se battent stable qui se monte pour
sortir du monde pourrait être le dernier
standing vous éliminer en douze autres
filets plus magique des filles du joueur
des enfants c'est vraiment juste mais on
met des grenades une cage qui
s'entretuent et je vais en gros c'est
début de la semaine et il ya une épreuve
pour choisir le patron de la maison le
patron de la maison va choisir deux
personnes à mettre le bloc le blog c'est
les gens qui vont être potentiellement
éliminé après ça ces deux personnes le
campaign pour essayer de qom
gardez les votes qui appréciaient va
avoir une autre preuve c'est qu'ils
appellent le power vite aux pisseurs
avec ça ils peuvent enlever quelqu'un du
bloc plus de la personne qui le gagne
dans cette compétition la sexy mettant
une personne qui est enlevée ça va être
une autre personne qui doit être mis sur
le blog pierre la fin de la semaine
une des deux doit absolument se faire
éliminer par les autres personnes la
maison faite le le but dans le fond
c'est de faire des alliances près
comment qu'ils ont on essaie tout comme
quelque chose pour virer fou le penses
tu que tu vaux genre de snap et ouais ok
tout le québec va devoir de virer
complètement faux départ mais j'essaye
le plus possible tu es comme parce que
ça va je me remets en question tout le
temps tout le temps sur mon caractère
sûr comme comment je suis juste à ses
six titres ont sorti puis là j'ai
l'impression que ça va être difficile de
basket et je veux pas comme l'historique
que je peux lui promettre j'aimais pop
hits comme l'imam en jeu mais phil
pagetti jeu le mans pole mais que je
pense que ça va être difficile d'avoir
un côté de moi qui mets challenge un peu
plus que ce poteau que le contrôle sur
ton image pillet je sais que beaucoup de
choses dans ma personnalité que je
trouve difficile
c'est à moi vivent avec fait que j'ai
vraiment par le sopi
mes carnets j'essaie de me rappeler que
à mon corps je sais que je suis une
bonne personne puis j'ai des bonnes
intentions puis que je veux le meilleur
pour tout le monde c'est georges c'est
que c'est ça que je veux fait qu'à la
fin de la journée je vais essayer de me
concentrer là dessus pour me dire
qu'elle reste chez converse aux
questions parce que vos virées shopping
compétitives ou où tu veux juste comme
laisser les choses aller piller et je
sais pas pourquoi pas je regarde le
chaud puis je suis comme ça a vraiment
l'air le fond dedans compétition puis ça
me tenterait pas l'arrivée l'ofppt
flirter qui sera jusqu'en finale parce
qu'à regarder les autres c'est l'humain
entre-autres pire est possible et parce
qu'elle poche dans la compétition le
fait que j'aimerais j'ai un feeling ça
va prendre mémoire mais j'espère que ça
va passer gérer j'aimerais ça être
populiste et réussir au moins une ou
deux compétitions sa saison cd d'être au
moins patron la maison une fois tu sais
j'aimerais ça le vivre pour ouvrir mai
j'espère simplement vous dire c'est si
la fille qu'on connaît c'est que vous
avez raté le savez pas à qui l'on n'a
pas pris dans ces cas demain ça
j'aimerais ça je pense que six titres
choisis quand est-ce que tu montres mais
petit on t'aime et on n'en mange
beaucoup le jeter sur les réseaux
sociaux petit monde quand même plusieurs
facilement plus que n'importe qui qui va
être chaud lecture fakty je pense je
pense quand même que cela lisons que les
gens connaissent et la vraie légende
puis tu dois être la vraie raison de la
brouille qui savons tous où de l affaire
c'est que je peux être très impatiente
et mettons que je suis en train de faire
quelque chose c'est par heure que je
pense que j'ai les mêmes jeux kali'na
l'humeur de toutes mes forces
maintenant si tu fais pas ça ok
maintenant la cenap plus d'y planter
tout bois plus de trois buts puis ça va
quand même temps chaque mois 5 mois
d'offre au jour le jour où ça m'a aidé
et petite journée où je commence je me
suis engagé un peu ce feeling mais n'ont
en général ça va mieux que jamais tu
penses tu que tu as raison qu'ils
récoltaient massa est absolument non
mais attends caracolait toujours été un
très gros problème mais si je me levais
tous les matins en me sentant coupable
de cette relation avec l'alcool ça a
gâché tellement de relation tellement
d'affaires dans ma vie c'est fou le
dommage que ça lui sur ma vie avec ça
fait du bien pis je sens 5 - us crise a
pas de bon sens l'ait le changement que
je vois dans tout le physique manger
changé en crise parce que moi je le vois
là et des des gens autour de moi ils
sont mieux si je me suis dit oh mon dieu
tu es tellement plus à l'écouté
cava du genre à te je sais pas il ya
comme mes projets toute l'école
cinq mois ça commence à être long pour
vrai le tc plus genre de dire j'arrête
de boire puis l'a fait craquer c'est un
mois puis tu recommences ou des tissus
cinq mois ci c'est ça commence à être
la dre sobriété personne n'y croyait
pour être le premier à dire que j'étais
moi d'entendre je vais arrêter bord
c'était bon à prendre personne que
j'entends dire ce que ça chie mode
mentalement après une semaine dont le
team et devoirs écoute c'est la
meilleure façon de les croire j'ai juste
d'inquiéter j'en parlais que php tisci
ce que tu décris ici même nous t on
n'est pas tant approche le métier jean
andré de la kasma bien tecteo de l'ère
nouvelle personne mais genre dans le bon
sens du terme
et est ce que c'est ça c'est vraiment
cool but et il me touche et polluant des
thèmes et ont travaillé ensemble mettons
lizard ça va tu être conflit qui
travaillaient avec puis genre c'était un
peu un rapport qui met tant le matin que
la boîte élevé cela ça la fin sinon ça
va mal c'est vraiment cool si j'avais
été encore à bord ça aurait été vraiment
plus difficile que ça a été souvent des
conflits et avec les gens tournent
souvent genre arrive a raconté cette
mauvaise passe que j'ai dit tout ce qui
me passe par la tête puis des fous déjà
que je fais déjà surtaxé
ces ruines et l'hébreu jeu d'enquêté de
bohème espace s'ajuste pas de classe le
jeu est ce que tu trouves que tu es bon
tu te retrouves toi ce que tu trouves
que
le fait je trouve qu'ils jettent au
second hamas c'est vraiment ça c'est
quand meme temp le à l'enfer l'enfant
comme caché au secondaire c'est quand
j'ai commencé à faire des vidéos sur
youtube à 14 ans et j'arrivais chez nous
de l'école puis je me souviens c'est
comme le shit s'est tapé ma chambre pour
faire une vidéo puis je me suis vraiment
nordistes faisaient du montage mettait
la musique et je me maquillais j'me
costume est petit c'était tout comme
j'étais tout le temps une pièce de
théâtre j'avais tout perdu phone by j'ai
complètement perdu et maintenant mon
seul fan ça me saoule et hallyday jeu ce
genre la seconde chez cambon qu'est ce
que je préfère pour ma musique je me
soulez mon plaisir est associée à ce
j'avais oublié que je pourrais avoir du
fun en faisant autre chose faite car
seconde période de boire faut que tu
retrouves d'autres plaisirs faut que tu
fasses bon qu'est ce que je fais pour
avoir du fun que j'ai commencé à
dessiner j'ai recommencé à jante
du coup les lui-même agrégé de cycle et
j'ai recommencé à jouer aux jeux vidéo
quelque chose que j'avais laissé tomber
puis que j'aime tellement genre je
remette du coeur l'un des projets puis
en garde je peux pas à ses conseillers
des autres que je veux pas pris deux
chars étaient d'abord parce qu'il faut
que c'est pas tout le monde qui a le
même problème que moi j'avais mais les
bric à brac de dépendance à quelque
chose j'aimerais même que wes cates et
le bois de façon saine mais ammann il ya
un très chaud doigt ce que tu quelqu'un
que ça tient sa nuitée relation des
projets tout est à faire mais le site
est un problème qui était débordé qui
bénéficierait à asaba l'été ou à régler
ce problème le même jour à moins content
pour toi c'est vraiment un coup vraiment
vraiment c'est là qu'est ce que je sais
c'est qu'au début quand passer ce mois
ci j'ai arrêté parce que chanter mais
quand même c'est mon jean puis j'avais
je faisais aucun vidéo sans avoir bu
d'alcool
et puis je me considérais si j'avais pas
d'alcool c'est même si c'était pas
beaucoup le dijon montbard de jean andré
crépeau
c'est pas comme la même docteur point
j'avais pour autant d'énergie fac au
début quand j'ai arrêté boes va arrêter
de faire des vidéos parce que jeter
comme je me sentais plus là je me
sentais poche
c'est ce que tu dis là de retrouver au
début c'est ce qu'il peut dire je pense
qu'on arrête de boire c'est de réaliser
que est bâtie comme moi je vais trouver
place achetée jadis en poche mais vidéo
ces chevauchements la fille partait
pieds sur terre et je m'étais isolés on
met mon team et les amis on les voyait
tout le temps jouer tout à rester à
maison parce que j'avais aucun intérêt
parce que je n'avais pas j'ai un peu de
fun dans ma taille fax et c'est vraiment
ça c'est les débuts puis à peu après
après 1 coupe de ça fait huit mois qui
écoute j'ai retrouvé le plaisir d'écrire
que tu es une femme face au très mal ce
site où le oui je sais même pas si après
j'ai ajouté
je verrai intérêts de thé oui peut-être
à l'occasion je sais pas là mais j'ai
beau gg c'est sûr que quand je vois mes
vidéos je pense pas que je vais or
mondial n'est comme avant - c'est à
chaque fois ces fous pareils moi je ne
maintiens ma relation que l'alcool ça
toujours été vraiment super a dit que le
des fois je me saouler pipi souvent je
prenais jamais d'alcool depuis l'autre
fois ça m'est arrivé de d'en faire une
crise de bonnes dit aussi que genre à
cette heure je checke moncel j
enregistre des vidéos de moi tout seul à
7 heures le matin complètement défoncé
la semaine après j'étais un tonneau pour
toutes les raisons l'otan me sucre avec
l'alcool mais autant que comme le la
grosse crise de soirée là pendant une
semaine je ne marque plus je me disais
je connais du monde qui font ça à toutes
les fins de semaine métier à tous les
jeunes qui ont besoin de tulle de partir
d'un même lot il y avait de l'accueil
avait la drogue je connais du monde qui
qui ont besoin de soultz souvent plus je
me disais
vraiment fun mais tape mac que ta vie
devient un choix de marques par exemple
rapidement un outil c'est comme le tard
à distance habituelle apparaître de
faire du port d'ars est de bouger tard
de faire des trucs qui tremble retard
est de type le creusent une tombe de
même tu deviens d'une larve latics le
vent se lève à 5 heures pm by qui quitte
le temps des fonds si j'écoute est
vraiment bon filon fait amène là dessus
c'est exactement ce dont on parle de son
film s'appelle ce film du danemark mais
en anglais c'est une drôle de nom du
fénoir situe le tu l'as acheté sur
l'essence il sait que je reçois un
message ses gammes vous venez d'acheter
un adorable bonne écoute cheikh ahmad
omid c'est bon je remarque à mai
puis ces genres 6-4 que jordan à 45
antenne noter qu'on y vit un peu
monotone plats typiques
parce que l'hypothèse principale que
jean tirand du plâtre avec sa femme
depuis que sa femme t il ya 5 cm et on
au secondaire ses élèves le trouve
plaques de plomb les 4 go ils font un
super plaignant des gueux qui parle
d'une théorie d'un certain psychologue
qui dirait que les hommes on a un
déficit de points 0/5 alcool type pour
être optimale
toujours à point 0,5 t comme à ton
meilleur train bleu ligety route est
taclé les griffons ok on peut juste
boire sur les heures de travail en bois
juste le jour qui on travaille on ne
peut pas boire passé huit ans le soir on
boit pas la fin de semaine c'est que ça
met tout le temps un peu d'alcool la
hâte une gourde splendor de bord de
l'eau plus qu'un qui travaillent sont
tout le temps un peu chaud tu as well au
début du film le très haut débit du film
ça va bientôt claude clair mat 10 puis
sauter au début le guide donne ses
copines comme plus d'appuis plus
pénibles ces élèves comme ils trouvent
plus haute l'ex affame les flambeaux sa
femme sa femme appelant cas pratiques
pis le thriller bloqué et on essaye une
coche de plus tacler on essaye à points
0,8 puis la manne et c'est comme s'il en
est c'est au blackout aurillac et ça
fait jaser c'est drôle à côté de moi
mais tu fais pas tant une comédie lol
c'est vraiment triste quand même
dramatique mais c'est faux king bons
collaborateurs s'appelait s'appelle à
nadal a glissé à long terme l'enfance et
sur des bus comme n'importe quoi comme
la drogue j'ai déjà essayé la maman
aline comme deux fois adopté au début de
ces gamins que je comprends pourquoi le
monde
ils font surtout c'est là que ça devient
comme tpu l'optique éclaire vraiment
wyeth avait au début tout cas ça devient
une routine plutôt que quelque chose
d'exceptionnel pour le fun c'est tes
toulouse au fameux marquer mais quand au
shooting photo te dit comment tu buvais
des bouteilles de vin par jour
geste de partage et au partage une story
il ya des gens qui se lèvent le matin
qui a 40 ans de votre club
jean royer 9 heures puis je pense que le
mécanisme s'est lui félicité car même
temps de votre que non jamais j'ai un
voyage à san francisco je m'en souviens
pu parce que dès la seconde que je tripe
la seconde que je suis parti j'ai bu je
ne me souviens de notre famille oui mon
grand père yvon et il était grave
alcoolique pied à cause de ça mon père
jamais vu de sa vie une goutte d'alcool
il sait pas que ça vaut les parents font
ouais c'est ce que m'a dit si tu mets
ton monte à quelque chose plus le parent
en transmet le gène sans même sans même
lever mon père c'est pour ça qu'il ya
jamais vu de sa vie ce parce qu'à cause
de sa vie qui était tout le temps sous
pie qui était et
ea été gravement blessé par l'alcoolisme
de mon grand père qui la mère de mon
grand père est décédé à cause de
l'alcool
si ce qui fait que mon grand père a
commencé à bord il y avait le jeu vous
regarder pourquoi que ma mère à situer
ce genre je l'essayé y est devenu
alcoolique on peut le dire ont parié
décidé qu'elle ait jamais bord de sa vie
à cause de ce mémoire en vieillissant je
suis tes parents exactement comme comme
typhon ou son petit nom mais je sais
comme et extrémisme aussi la canade et
ça c'est vraiment toi que tu fais mon
frère m'a fallu jamais il voit jamais il
fait beau et puis c'est sûrement à andré
qui dit que le site de l'école et de ta
famille tu as la chance et même à faire
du côté de ma mère maintenant même à
faire toute ma famille a dit comprendre
la boisson mais bref il étudie la cob de
gourdon et oui il va en avoir pas tout
le temps dans les journées de congé qui
est contrôlée mais moi je n'en prendrais
aucun culte - qui boivent autour de toi
ça te fait sur quelque chose
j'ai lu tout le monde ça seul genre la
première être comme ça déjà
j'étais ivre à travers les offres qui
pousse à te paul genre ça te dérange pas
d'enfant donnant un goût de toi maman
pendant j'aime savoir du monde autour de
moi ça me fait rire ça me fait bien
chaud quand j'ai encore l'impression
d'être des mecs passent pas qui aimait
tant le contexte avec le stress pile
contexte il a fait cas de la halle que
la beauce sorte on sait très peu de tout
on peut défendre jeudi matin je pense
que jean mon rapport à mon image de
stress d'aller lopy de quoi je vais
avoir l'air et déjà assisté avec je
boirai pas en plus pour aux sites que
j'ai de la gamme s'adresse à la fois
c'est pas le goût d'avoir la réponse est
oui mais c'est vrai que les gens boivent
alentours de nous moi des fois le était
en bois une zone de moussu sans alcool
de piqué
ben arfa le placebo le monde souche a au
passage suis pas seul mois mais claire
va droit dans une télé réalité ce n'est
pas ses frontières tout le monde cas de
la fenifoot deux hôtes c'est cissé qui
ont troubles d'importance même manège à
l'air quand même bien l'alcool puis je
deviens points 2,5 puis quand je regarde
au déballage fait comme si la photo est
débout tout ce que je bats mais c'est
comme le partez pas par une gentille
mais je suis juste devient juste comme
going beaucoup plus long le chemin j'ai
comme un casse tête avec comme couette
buzzer comme ceux de la peinture d'enfer
sam était maintenant quelqu'un qui tient
pas l'alcool devient tabarnak
at-on le tissu bleu ce panel de tabarnak
mais pas celle entre les mêmes effets on
vous remercie vraiment bail à 20 avant
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai on a des
cadeaux on a des cadeaux kadéos les
jours
on va les nourrir en live sur vos
demandes et garda de le tanneur pour ré
nicole aussi notre technicien c'est tout
la même chose que dans un sens oui
balises ans parce que la nageuse waszak
non oui ce chat mais pour paris bon on
devrait lui au bon prix revu ensemble
doit lancer comme quelque chose juste
qu'il ne savait pas au mieux
moi je vais être honnête je n'ai 0
jouets sexuels ou objets sexuels j'ai du
loup jean augé du loup boudjellal et du
lobby des condoms cette fois que j'ai
jamais essayé rien c'est que j'en ai
besoin parce est pas à quai en a
peut-être j'essayais web il ya deux mois
- ok mais c'est pas avoir su honnêtement
je vous a ramené mon autre de voir le
que je bouffe özil mégarde
on commence par sur pied de façon tu
nous la mènerons notre devoir on va
l'essayer puis à la pression viendra sur
votre poids de 15 points par ce serait
une bonne chose parce qu'est ce que
c'est que c'est du sirop d'érable fait
au québec
ici je suis donc ça c'est pas érotique
c'est faux et c'est toujours l'érable
pour me montrer est ce parce qu'elle
fait là s'y rend fier ça salit les drops
tu veux en fait souvent inclinée gamin
tu veux pas avoir de poils pubiens quand
une aide sur les là parce que sinon
sajama poids mais j'avoue c'est cool
mais merci merci beaucoup s'est brisé
sur demande les samares
mais ça va avec l'autre avec l'auxerrois
exact ok c'est quoi c'est quoi c'est
quoi kim d j'ai rien à voir là bas il
est vraiment la classe bon c'est ce
qu'on pourrait est ce que c'est ce qu'on
appelle fleshlight c'est quoi ce bail
fait chasser le nom d'une marque mr
masturbateur attaque
oui des meilleurs qui il ya plein de
textos l'intérieur et ses fruits pour
l'environnement ouais mais c'est
vraiment l'fun parce qu'ils vivent ça
c'est vu que vous savez pas encore si
vous aimez la fération pauvres ils
étaient coupées les attentes les uns des
autres mais l'ouvrir maintenant moi je
vais je mets mon pénis repérées cela
date c'était ben c'est tellement le fun
ça fait différent légaux quel argent
pour ceux qui nous écoutent juste en
audio le jeu pourrait par conséquent
cela finit paul m l'ouvré boîte de fac
et c'est le fun c'est vraiment classe c
kom sa fuite dans un sac à main je
prends l'avion je connais toi si ce
n'est toi c'est avec ben légaux les
filles nettoyante spectre il convient de
jouer mais les goûte peu la vis avec eux
n'est pas que du savon c'est ton pénis
tu l'avais de salomon l'ofac effet que
seule la salle à la texture d'une gelée
tenue après ouais
lamar mckay week-end c'est la vibration
le rouge ça s'étire ça fait toutes les
grosseurs qui est devenu en mai à yvette
du liberia puis mettez deux voix près de
20 cm ce qui est sûr c'est du lourd mais
moi je sais pas ce que je veux qu'on
fasse la théâtre complet fait ce qui
nous attend ce moment je récite décrire
bien que je peux ce que je vois le genre
de deux tubes beige en penser à la
gélatine t1 pagé lathus qui vivra pas
rambo pire est depuis le pilote et moi
c'est ça pèse 3 5 ans ouais c'est
vraiment être pour masquer les cadeaux
qui sauvent avec qui ça peut être un
couple ça fait changement puis
à logan bac 6 mai au pays du soleil à
base de dos à base d'eau pour les jouets
toujours ok ok bien on va mettre deux
doigts puis gros doigts mais ça c'est
bon je sais je sais que les doigts le
mât sommet doit les autres genre tu fais
ce juste seul ça me détend le jeu
rentrer les doigts puis je pourrais
amener à l'école je dois je trouve que
c'est vraiment hot pour les doigts gelés
je sais pas mais tu vois le mercy est
rechargeable donc pas de batterie fakir
et amusez vous les gars merci qui
s'est ralenti j'aimerais peut-être aussi
éventuellement me procurer un jeep hop
je pense que notre parole winch hip hop
ça c'est oui demandent tout tout me
procure ça c'est le mien c'est le sait
ce que c'est assez clair cela qu'il fait
qu'on écoute votre podcast sexe oral qui
va sortir les jeudis puis ça va être des
biens on a déjà enregistré 11 épisodes
vous avez déjà enregistré 11 épisodes
qui vont sortir pendant qu'ils en est à
big brother et la note que tu reviens
totoro qu'une idée ça écho à la
réception quand il est là bas ça va
tourner la page avant d'autres choses à
penser en plus ça va bien aller motion
pour que mon nom mais ce moment surtout
ça va bien aller
merci beaucoup les filles merci